[Music]
welcome to the future future
trials fusion blast you with a cheesy
energetic song when you fire it up it's
so catchy and so ridiculous that I
switched between loving it sincerely and
ironically a hundred different times but
I do love it and it sets the mood
wonderfully for the insane events that
are about to unfold trials fusion so
beautifully melds goofiness with tough
as nails racing that it's hard to wipe
the smile from your face as you crash
repeatedly on your way to victory so
what's changed from the previous trials
games not much you once again find
yourself on 2d tracks complete with all
manner of ramps and obstacles except now
you're in a post-apocalyptic landscape
which man and machine have finally
merged or fused so you need only worry
about managing your acceleration and
leaning such simple tasks prove
consistently difficult and engaging
because of the fantastic course design
as you drive through the first half of
trials fusion perfection is in your
sights just keep your momentum as you
land tricky jumps to shave seconds off
your time and avoid embarrassing
pratfalls
beginner easy and medium difficulties
rope you in with their creative layouts
and enticing aesthetics and there's an
innate Pole to better your score you're
not going to let the ghost representing
your buddy get the better of you are you
although there is a multiplayer mode
it's the leaderboard challenges that
provide the best competition so you lean
and gun the throttle like a pro recently
navigating the bumpy roads the finish
line
it's when you enter the hard courses
that trials takes on a different feeling
the dreams of catching your friend or
finishing without one crash have
evaporated now it's just about survival
seemingly impossible jumps await you and
it takes all your nerve and dedication
to overcome their nastiness
instantaneous restarts pop you back on
the track without a moment to breathe
and the minutes fly by before you even
realize it it's mind over matter what
anyone can triumph if they have the
patience
I hit both the literal and figurative
wall towards the tail under the hard
tracks but I didn't let getting stuck
stop me from having fun so I went back
to my old stomping grounds to improve my
times whereas I struggled in some of
those early tracks now ow is more skill
I could keep my speed and balance
throughout trials fusion is built
entirely on your abilities there's no
luck here nothing cheap or unfair so
when you do achieve a perfect run or
fast a devious track you feel as el
you've earned it and when I'm left back
to those hard tracks I finally cross the
finish line tricks and previous trials
games were limited to dangerous front
and back flutes and now you can perform
even crazier boots and their tracks
designed just for your lunacy by just
using the right stick you can perform
masochistic maneuvers that would make
your mom sick holding a Superman pose
until the last possible second shows
your guile and ieave it a but landing
that trick feels so good that it's worth
pushing yourself as far as your rider
can go there are challenges on every
course to give you a bevy of unique
objectives - some require raw skills
such as not leaning throughout a run
whereas others about exploration where
are the flowers hidden and others well
bring your barf bag unless you enjoy
playing upside down challenges do a
great job of mixing up how to play and
give you an exciting detour when you're
struggling in a standard race trials
fusion is an excellent representation of
the fantastic racing that this series
has become known for sharp controls and
understandable physics keep success
formally in your hands and the diversity
in the courses ratchet up the surprises
and forces you to use all of your
abilities
the one place fuse and stumbles is in
its creation tools incredible powers at
your fingertips
it's just harnessing it that's a problem
there's no in-game tutorial instead
you're pointed towards a YouTube page
the tools themselves are unintuitive and
then the course is glitchy it's all too
easy to fall into the ground or get
stuck on or off which means you have to
go back to the drawing board a lot to
iron out those kinks those who love
creating courses will be able to conjure
up amazing experiences
but the barrier for entry is far too
high for those who just want to play
around still for those who love
competing trows fusion is another great
entry in the franchise from the goofy
intro song to the rag doll crashes
you'll laugh throughout but it takes
dedication and skill to master the many
courses welcome to the future just
beware of stray missiles
[Music]